bonsoir nous sommes jeudi 18 février
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
entouré de nos invités également des
journalistes de la rédaction
tout de suite lé titre de cette édition
le projet des fresques du vally bout va
enfin voir le jour annoncé depuis
plusieurs années il a été présenté hier
soir officiellement aux habitants de
plaisir
explications à suivre et si l'exposition
universelle 2025 avait lieu en france la
candidature va être déposé au mois
d'avril
présentation du projet qui pourrait
peut-être concernés versailles
et puis on sport l'équipe de basket du
chesnay versailles 78 tu viens
accueillir une nouvelle recrue de l'as
américain sylvester morgan qui a évolué
au plus haut niveau
le point dans notre chronique sport du
jeudi et l'hôpital charcot implantée à
plaisir va subir un vrai lifting
construit au début des années 60 les
quatre pavillons actuelle installés dans
le centre psychiatrique vont être
totalement réhabilité un bâtiment
flambant neuf de 14 mille mètres carrés
devraient sortir de terre en mars 2018
le projet était attendue depuis plus de
dix ans par les patients on écoute tout
de suite le directeur du centre
hospitalier jacques bérard et des têtes
au micro dé michael almy d'euros c'est
un grand soulagement c'est un chantier
qui qui est très atypique du fait de
nombreuses défections technique et
erreurs techniques juridiques et c'est
assez exceptionnel en france d'ailleurs
mais c'est un grand soulagement
effectivement pour l'équipe de direction
et pour aussi les personnes de l'étude
de la direction espace technique qui
travaille depuis des mois et des mois
pour faire redémarrer ce chantier et le
coût global de l'opération s'élèvera à
20 5 millions d'euros financés par
l'hôpital avec l'aide de l'agencé
régionale de santé
les travaux devraient débuter avant cet
été et nous restons donc à plaisir ce
sera une première en ile-de-france des
fresques géantes vont être dessinés sur
les façades des bâtiments dans le
quartier du val hibou un secteur qui
compte près de 1000 logements la
première réunion de lancement de ce
projet était organisée ce mercredi soir
à la mosaïque
les détails avec mitchell et demi
d'euros et fanny bourdillon le dossier
était dans les cartons depuis près trois
ans des fresques géantes devront être
dessinés sur les façades des bâtiments
dans le quartier du vert bois plaisir
une réunion publique était programmée ce
mercredi soir à la mosaïque pour lancer
le projet le présenter aux plaisirs war
c'est de l'émotion carrément cessé
d'émotion parce que quand on sait
l'impact que cela peut avoir
ce projet là ces fresques que j'ai pu
voir dans d'autres quartiers à lyon des
quartiers difficiles
combien ça a changé complètement
l'atmosphère et le regard même des
autres sur le quartier javaux coeur on
ne peut être qu'ému de voir ce lancement
à ce projet ils m'ont chante beaucoup
parce que
j'ai connu malibu d'avant elle valide ou
d'aujourd'hui est aujourd'hui à traves
raiman permettent d'égayer le quartier
pour dessiner ses frais ce que
l'entreprise cité création a été retenu
le leader mondial en design urbain 40
ans d'existence a déjà réalisé plus de
600 fresque à travers le monde
nous on écrit des histoires sur les murs
qui sont la peau des habitants
c'est comme ça qu'on définit sur
plusieurs décennies pour que leurs
enfants leurs parents puissent voir
s'écrire sous nos yeux dans la durée
l'histoire d'un quartier
tout ça bien sûr très bien intégré au
niveau architectural et urbanistique
les dessins sont créés en concertation
avec les 4000 habitants du quartier ils
proposeront des thèmes au peintre ça va
être un peu l'histoire du quartier nous
qui sommes là depuis des années on va
tous pouvoir participer et donner nos
souvenirs et nos anecdotes et j'espère
que ça va bien se passer
le budget n'a pas été dévoilée pendant
cette réunion de lancement la mairie
s'est engagée à ne pas participer au
financement de l'opération
la conception des fresques devrait
débuter en septembre pour une livraison
prévue à l'horizon 2017 et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines poursuit son
offre d'accueil et de logement après les
résidences étudiantes se sont maintenant
des hôtels qui vont voir le jour aux
abords du vélodrome à national de
montigny le bretonneux deux
établissements hôteliers de près de 200
chambres doivent être livrés dans un peu
plus d'un mois les détails avec mélanie
poker ils sont à quelques pas seulement
du vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines dans un mois ces deux hôtels
offriront 180 chambres
les nuitées qui sont vendus chez rocher
ou saint quentin en yvelines répondent à
une demande des salariés des
collaborateurs des entreprises qui ont
besoin de se loger
un jour deux jours trois jours là le
positionnement de ce2
de cet hôtel sur l'exode rom permet
aussi de pouvoir répondre à des sportifs
des familles qui viennent pour des
événements sportifs avec 22 hôtels et
deux résidences hôtelières
l'agglomération dispose d'un parc de
plus de 1800 chambre ces deux
établissements vise la convivialité les
changes avec de grands espaces l'enjeu
aujourd'hui des hôtels c'était en sorte
que les gens puissent puissent se
rencontrer aussi dans les lobbys dans
les lieux d'accueil donc on n'est plus
sûr des sectes sur des pièces très
segmenté comme on l'a aujourd'hui dans
une telle qu'ils ont déjà quelques
années on est sur quelque chose une
composition ce qu'ils sont en train de
réaliser comme aménagement et décoration
de rez de chaussée de l'hôtel qui qui va
être assez sympa leur livraison est
attendue pour le 31 mars un projet
d'immeuble d'entreprise est aussi lancée
et nous allons parler économie à présent
nous recevons en plateau ce soir le
nouveau président du réseau entreprendre
jean claude robert bonsoir à vous et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors vous venez d'être intronisé donc
c'était hier soir vous êtes vous-même
chef d'entreprise vous dirige un groupe
de cinq sociétés dans le secteur de
l'étang têtu de l'étanchéité pardon de
toiture et vous avez été un des membres
fondateurs du réseau d'entreprendre
finalement c'est une passation pouvoir
logique d'écouté oui on peut le dire
comme ça depuis 2000 2008 2009
nous avons créé le réseau entreprendre
en yvelines
pierre viol a dirigé pendant maintenant
cette année en tant que président
fondateur et donc hier soir il a passé
la main et les administrateurs ont bien
voulu me confier cette tâche
alors l'objectif du réseau entreprendre
on l'a rappelé et donc d'aider les
entrepreneurs
effectivement notre objectif c'est
d'aider entre des entrepreneurs avec
comme corollaire la création d'emploi
s'est essentiellement ça qui nous
intéresse pour aider ces entrepreneurs
on a un certain nombre de dispositifs
des prêts d'honneur qui leur permettent
d'améliorer leurs fonds propres à
l'accompagnement c'est fondamental ça
leur permet de ne pas être seul d'avoir
un véritable miroir avec eux voilà sous
les chênes entreprises qui sont alors
disponibles pour être très concret il ya
vraiment un par un parrainage entre les
entrepreneurs qui viennent rejoindre
votre réseau est un des chefs
d'entreprise qui les accompagne dans
leur progression
exactement mais le chef d'entreprise qui
accompagne le lauréat c'est comme ça que
nous n'appelons pas la compagne pendant
deux ans environ une fois par mois
véritable suivi plus que du coaching
c'est vraiment un vrai partenariat
alors tous les entrepreneurs peuvent se
faire accompagner par les entreprises
crois qu'il ya une sélection quand même
c'est assez rigoureuses véritable
sélection
créateurs ou repreneurs d'entreprise
s'adresse aux deux aux deux types
d'entrepreneurs peut effectivement faire
cette demande doit présenter un dossier
bien ficelé comme on dit il est
accompagné déjà dense est dans la
préparation du dossier par un de nos
membres
je rappelle que nos membres sont tous
bénévoles tout chef d'entreprise
et lorsque le dossier nous semble nous
semble prêt il peut passer dans un
comité d'engagement qui va le valider ou
non donc on a quand on passe au comité
d'engagement la probabilité d'être
lauréat est très forte
alors quels sont les critères de
sélection justement critère numéro un
c'est la personne
on s'intéresse avant tout aux chefs
d'entreprise on veut s'assurer qu'ils
effectivement cette personne sera à même
de diriger son entreprise et de faire
face aux éventuels aléas de la vie
l'entrepreneur deuxième critère l'emploi
c'est vraiment important et l'emploi
dans les yvelines pour ce qui nous
intéresse nous donc voilà est-ce qu'il
va y avoir une création d'emplois est ce
que le projet nous semble viable
ce sont des critères déjà suffisamment
importants crédits sont accordés sont
financés par vous en partie alors ce qui
est très très important et ce qui est
vraiment fait la caractéristique de ce
réseau c'est que les il ya des prêts
bien évidemment ce sont des on appelle
ça des prêts d'honneur ces prêts
d'honneur essentiellement l'argent nous
provient de la caisse des dépôts de la
région également plus du département
malheureusement puisque le département
il se trouve sans fond trop important à
distribuer on va dire justement c'était
un problème a presque là les baisses de
dotations sont cette année ça a eu un
gros impact pour le réseau travaillant
pour l'instant on va dire que l'impact
n'a pas encore été trop trop trop
important il est certain qu'il faut que
l'on trouve les financements pour
poursuivre notre développement
c'est également important de souligner
c'est que
il ya deux poches dans le fonctionnement
du réseau entreprendre une poche qu'on
peut appeler fonctionnement une autre
poche prêts d'honneur prêts d'honneur je
viens de parler au niveau du
fonctionnement
ce sont les membres cette entreprise qui
finance ce réseau ce qui me donne une
liberté totale
voilà par rapport par rapport à tous les
décideurs éventuels qui sont un petit
peu les parents sont nés des chefs
d'entreprise à yves binois à ce sont
essentiellement des chocs des chefs
d'entreprise des yvelines bien sûr alors
ça peut éventuellement être des chefs
d'entreprise qui habitent les yvelines
et qui ont leur entreprise ailleurs
essentiellement c'est essentiellement
des yvelinois mais bien sûr pour un peu
resté avec les jeunes entrepreneurs qui
sont sont parfois isolés quand ils
montent leur entreprise également un
volet voilà sociale accompagnement à un
chef d'entreprise bien sûr est isolée ça
c'est sûr il a également besoin d'un
accompagnement pour le financement le
financement c'est une chose qui est
extrêmement délicate
je crois qu'on peut dire que quand on a
le label réseau entreprendre
et banquiers sont beaucoup plus
attentifs
nous avons d'ailleurs des banques
partenaires qui partir du moment où on a
donné notre validation sont beaucoup
plus enclines à aider alors si on sait
justement un petit peu grande le bilan
de cette année 2015 convient
d'entreprendre à vous accompagner ce que
c'est une bonne année
parce que en vue de la crise économique
parfois on peut se demander ce que ça
alors match mais on peut dire que cette
année on a eu moins de moins de dossiers
à aider on avait des 14 dossiers en 2015
oui effectivement je pense qu'on peut
dire qu'il ya eu un peu de cette crise
qui est passée par là le nombre de
dossiers le nombre de candidats
potentiels se sont un peu réduits donc
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il nous faut
faire savoir que le réseau entreprendre
existe et voilà tous les candidats
potentiels doivent nous contacter
justement ici pour accompagner et vous
cherche aussi des bénévoles pour
accompagner les entrepreneurs c'est le
corollaire bien sûr pour pouvoir
accompagner ces lauréats il nous faut
des bénévoles des bell chaîne entreprise
si possible en activité on a on a
plusieurs types de bénévoles bien sûr on
a des chefs d'entreprise on va dire
retraités qui sont qui sont qui ont
quitté la direction de leur entreprise
on a un certain nombre de parrains
également aux divers comme des avocats
des commissions compte nous aider aussi
vous êtes donc dans la vie autrement
depuis le début votre réservation que
votre analyse ce qu'il ya de plus en
plus de jeunes de personnes qui veulent
se lancer dans l'entreprenariat ou
est-ce que avec les dernières années la
crise économique vont observer être ni
trop froide et sans réticence moi je
trouve pas je trouve qu'il ya de
nombreux jeunes qui veulent se lancer
d'ailleurs où on voit d'ailleurs cette
nouvelle économie qu'on appelle hubert
isation les pas de lui d'ailleurs c'est
très délicat parce que parce que pour un
certain nombre de chefs d'entreprises
dont je fais partie d'ailleurs c'est pas
toujours très simple on a besoin
d'ailleurs au niveau des membres qui
nous qui veulent nous rejoindre on a
besoin de jeunes le jeune entrepreneur
qui comprendront certainement encore
mieux que que nous un peu plus anciens
mais bon on a besoin de femmes aussi ça
je voulais le dire aussi vous avez une
formation entreprendre au féminin est la
destination qui veulent se lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat c'est un vrai projet
qui est soutenu par le nôtre réseau
national
d'ailleurs cette année nous avons lu
vaincu % de des candidats lauréats qui
sont des
les femmes donc c'est vraiment très très
bien et on est nettement au dessus des
normes nationales on va dire qu'on part
au niveau national la politique parmi du
gouvernement étaient des annonces qui
pour aider les business angel est
justement aussi les entrepreneurs c'est
une bonne chose pour vous le contre
entrepreneurs aussi c'est quelque chose
voilà qu'ils aient une bonne bonne idée
un bon élan pour jeter un entrepreneur
ils ont dit déjà adieu à ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'on fait pas de politique
au niveau de réseau entreprendre ça
c'est vraiment important
ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'à partir du
moment où nos gouvernants pense que pour
créer des emplois il faut que les
employeurs et des entrepreneurs je pense
qu'ils vont dans la bonne direction
c'est ce qu'on fait depuis depuis 1985
sur les zones existent où ça c'est
vraiment très important et toute
décision qui peut nous permettre
d'entreprendre d'employer plus de monde
forcément dans la bonne direction
est ce que si voilà vous deviez donner
quelques conseils à des jeunes
entrepreneurs qui souhaitent se lancer
quel savatier et revoir donc faut taper
sur sur l'internet
réseau entreprendre yvelines ils y
arrivent ils seront parfaitement
accueilli et donc on est là pour les
aider on les a pour les faire réussir
surtout faire un dossier parce que c'est
parfois ne veut pas et les pâtes bien
plus difficile à faire justement
vraiment allez vous voir vous contacter
par internet
il rate sur catia internet téléphone
bien évidemment où on s'assure que que
le chef d'entreprise candidat va tenir
la route
et puis et puis rapidement on voit si on
peut ou non l'aider à monter un dossier
ça va assez vite
les dernières actualités annoncé pour
2016 lors des grands événements et qui
ont une interview à écouter réseau
entreprendre fait cela fait de ces
lauréats tous les ans à versailles au
palais des congrès on reçoit énormément
de monde bien évidemment tous les ans
c'est l'événement c'est l'événement pour
nous et puis sinon bah écoute et on
essaie de favoriser encore plus la
croissance avec un système qu'on appelle
entreprendre croissance qui permet
encore encore plus par un but par des
prêts d'honneur plus important d'aider
les gens qui veulent des doubles et
leurs activités merci beaucoup
jean claude robert d'avoir répondu à
noter semble avoir accepté nos
habitations
si voilà le réseau entreprendre vous
intéresse que vous souhaitez peut-être
en faire partie n'hésitez pas à aller
sur site un talent qui s'affiche en bas
de votre écran vous y retrouverez toutes
les informations nécessaires merci à
vous et la tournée deux candidature de
la france pour l'exposition universelle
de 2025 commence aujourd'hui jeudi 18
février à marseille sur le vieux-port
une tournée qui se poursuivra dans 16
grandes villes pour défendre sa
candidature
la france n'a pas pris en charge
l'événement depuis 1900 alors afin
d'expliquer pour la france l'intérêt
d'organiser cette exposition une
présentation du projet avait lieu hier
soir à versailles regarder
cinq expositions universelles ont déjà
eu lieu à paris au cours du 19ème siècle
et si nous avons notre célèbre tour
eiffel c'est même grâce à celles de 1889
la prochaine exposition pourrait avoir
lieu en 2025 en france de quoi
intéresser les curieux ils sont venus
nombreux à l'université interâges de
versailles pour en savoir un peu plus
sur le projet l'exposition universelle
c'est le monde entier qui regardent que
ce soit la beauté l'intérêt de la
culture l'art l'histoire et l'avenir
depuis 10 ans déjà l'association expo
france 2025 travail sur sa candidature
si son coût s'élève à près de 25
millions d'euros les retombées
économiques devraient aller au delà des
23 milliards
un événement d'ampleur qui attire entre
50 et 60 millions de touristes pas de
constructions hors norme pour cette
édition mais un village global installé
au coeur du grand paris
chaque ville de france pourrait
également proposer un site c'est un
projet qui adresse l'ensemble du
territoire français avec un une
centralité qui sera en ile-de-france
avec des sites satellites qui serait
dans les grandes métropoles françaises
et puis toute une série de parcours à
travers la france pour que le visiteur
puisse parcourir l'ensemble de
l'ensemble de nos territoires et
l'ensemble du territoire français donc
mais aussi peut-être les yvelines dans
le concept qui est aujourd'hui présentée
à rome pour l'exposition universelle
il y à des villes qui vont être
impliqués et c'est vrai que versailles
est assez naturellement par sa
réputation mondiale d'histoire de
versailles peut faire partie
cet événement le projet français devrait
être placée sous le signe du numérique
et la france déposera officiellement sa
candidature dès le mois d'avril
elle compte déjà parmi ses concurrents
les pays bas le japon et le brésil et
pour connaître le pays organisateur il
faudra un petit peu patienter à
l'automne 2008 les 167 états membres de
l'organisation internationale auront à
se prononcer par un vote
selon la règle un pays une voix sur la
ville ou la région qui accueillera
l'exposition universelle de 2025 et nous
recevons à présent sur ce plateau notre
journaliste sportif mutuelles elles
d'euros pour sa traditionnelle chronique
sport du jeudi bonsoir mutuelle saffron
je suis ravi de vous retrouver c'est mon
moment préféré de la semaine aujourd'hui
à nous allons parler de basket et plus
particulièrement de l'équipe du chesnay
versailles l'équipe qui évolue dans le
championnat excellence a fait signer un
joueur d'exception mois de janvier
signature presque improbable celle de
sylvester morgan le pivot de 2 mètres 06
âgé de 32 ans a évolué dans le très
relevé championnat universitaire à
georgia state il a ensuite parcouru le
monde en tant que basketteur
professionnel il a joué au venezuela au
japon au mexique au guatemala et j'en
passe un vrai globe trotter et
maintenant il défend les couleurs du
chesnay versailles
il nous explique son chant française et
j'étais blessé au genou venir en france
où ce sont moins de deux semaines
alors elle me l'a présenté à frais des
deux coaches qu'elle connaît
essayer de rejouer ce n'est pas loin de
chez moi et je connais l'emploi je pense
que c'est une bonne situation
on est tous très contents de l'avoir
récupérée donc c'est vraiment une très
belle opportunité pour nous parce que un
joueur de ce calibre à ce niveau là
c'est très rare en fait ça n'existe pas
et c'est vrai que j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir le récupérer et on est très
satisfait de ce qui nous attend morgan
est aujourd'hui l'un des meilleurs
marqueurs de l'équipe et il a notamment
marqué 18 points à l'extérieur contre
lemelin
les cats également une dizaine de
rebonds par match il nous présente son
jeu parfois joue avec beaucoup de
puissance
je suis une combinaison entre kevin
garnett et des joueurs comme tim duncan
jeu dos au panier
je tire je dribble et je passe la balle
ce qui fait de mon joueur jeu unique
coureurs quand on en a besoin et je peux
être défensif comme karl est contraint
de marquer car le défend ni contre c'est
vraiment une quelqu'un qui gênent même
sa présence la gêne les attaquants
adverses et monaco tes baskets et comme
j'ai aussi un côté humain il a apporté
un fonds de confiance au groupe qu'on
avait on avait un peu de mal que les
récents à l'est pas et serait que bon on
voit toute la différence
c'est quelqu'un va ont très hâte ruiz
donc pas là bas on compte sur les bons
kilomètres des points parce que voilà
c'est une arme offensive mais c'est
resté de rendre poindre au meilleur les
autres et il faisait pas si les romans
très polyvalent et est très collective
avec son arrivée le chesnay-versailles
au bord de la relégation revis le club a
enchaîné trois victoires consécutives et
pointe désormais à la sixième place du
classement
on n'avait pas d'intention jusqu'à
présent ça qu'on en faisait avec les
moyens du bord ce qu'on avait perdu des
joueurs en début de saison donc
les résultats n'avaient pas forcément
hélas vrai que depuis qu'il est là bas
ça ordis comme le pivot américain
sylvester morgan pour rester aux chaînés
à l'issue de la fin de la saison les
négociations n'ont pas encore débuté
débuté mais elle devrait commencer dans
les prochaines semaines
on suivra avec attention l'évolution de
cette situation on vous en reparlera sur
tv fil 78
je me demande et mickaël vous parlez de
la ligue universitaire la nsia et est-ce
que c'est très différent oui le gouffre
est quand même assez conséquents mais on
va dire que tous les meilleurs joueurs
passent par le niveau universitaire donc
le niveau est très bon mais la nba c'est
un autre monde
merci mutuelle pour cette précision on
passe à présent rendez vous sportif à ne
pas manquer ce week-end dans les
yvelines il y aura notamment du football
oui floral de versailles recevra bobigny
ce dimanche à 15h dans l'antre du stade
mont boron à l'occasion de la 16e
journée de dh et versailles et occupe
actuellement la troisième place du
classement à cinq longueurs du 2e les
mureaux une victoire pourrait donc leur
permettre de recoller au deuxième mais
attention versailles reste sur deux
défaites consécutives et jours ne sont
pas à l'abri d'une contre performance
et on termine à part dire une villa non
plus versailles ne devra pas perdre la
survie du club dépend mutuelle le match
sera peut être décisif dans la course au
maintien en fédérale 3 versailles
dernier du classement reçoit pithiviers
qui est 7e le match sera sous haute
tension en cas de défaite versé se
dirigeraient tout droit vers la division
honneur un championnat qui n'ont pas
connu depuis près de dix ans on leur
souhaite évidemment bon courage je vais
d'ailleurs les encourager ce week-end
fort qu'elle votre week-end s'annonce
passionnant on vous retire dans quelques
instants avec le votre tall que si on
parlait sport dites moi quel programme
un petit teasing alors nous parlerons
des jo de 2024 qui seront en partie
organisé à saint quentin en yvelines
vous parlerons du vendée globe 2016 deux
illinois participeront à la compétition
florian dis donc un gros programme en
perspective je tirais léger m'installer
en loges pour admirer vos prouesses
merci beaucoup à michel et à la proche
des vacances une idée insolite pour vos
sorties l'association orcines de city
vous propose de découvrir à cheval des
lieux insolites et aussi historique
sephora namani et camille lambert se
sont rendus dans le parc du château de
groupe ou c'est du côté de montfort
l'amaury à cheval
regardez le château dans lequel on est
a été le dix neuvième une fois que les
propriétaires en fait durant ses voyages
durant leur voyage à être ans a ramené
les petits souvenirs donc on peut
traverser différents continents dans le
parc on a plusieurs folie comme cette
pagode au pas au trot ou au galop
plonger dans l'histoire du parc
anglo-chinois du château de grousset
avec baptiste auclair fondateur de horse
in the city
l'association propose des promenades à
cheval dans les parcs des châteaux de
grousset versailles ou encore dans les
domaines de chevreuse saint cloud et
boulogne
mais j'ai créé ce concept parce que
c'est vrai que sur paris genre trouvé
qu'il y avait pas beaucoup d'offres sur
des promenades juste pour hu à
l'occasion
voilà on est beaucoup de cavaliers à
être montés enfants adolescents et après
souvent les gens arrêtent l'équitation
et ont par la suite ont vite il s'y
remettre mais ils ont pas envie
forcément de s'inscrire toutes les
semaines on est court mais juste de
profiter sur des journées de beau temps
de promenade à l'occasion la balade peut
également être couplée à une visite
historique
l'occasion de découvrir pour les
cavaliers débutants et aguerris de
nouveaux décors comme la bibliothèque du
château de brousse est construit en 1815
et son thé être inaugurée en 1957 par la
comédie française
un concept sur mesure l'idée c'est quand
même d'aller dans des lieux un peu
atypique d'aller où on n'attend pas trop
le cheval on organise des promenades
privé et du coup à partir de là en fait
toutes les tous les scénarios sont
possibles
donc ça et qu'on peut on a déjà
scénarisé des promenades avec le demande
en mariage
trois heures d'activités proposées en
français et en anglais dont deux heures
de pratique à cheval et pour récompenser
l'effort
la balade se termine par un pique nique
en compagnie des moniteurs et c'est la
fin de cette édition je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivis dont quelques instants
à 19h30 vous retrouver michael elle me
d'euros et ses invités pour le talk show
si une part les sports il vous l'a dit
l'instant programme les jeux olympiques
de 2024 et la course du landais globe
demain vous retrouvez wilfried est richy
pour l'essentiel de l'actualité de la
semaine quant à moi je vous retrouve l
lundi pour une nouvelle édition du
journal je vous souhaite donc une
excellente soirée et un très bon week
end